until yesterday there were at least
three Americans unlawfully detained in
Russia Paul wellin a former Marine
arrested on Espionage charges Mark Fogle
a 61 year old history teacher arrested
for possessing a small amount of medical
marijuana and Brittany Greiner a young
anti-American lady basketball player
arrested for the same crime for the the
marijuana
two of those people are still stuck
doing hard labor in Russia one gets to
go home can you guess which one Britney
is uh is an incomparable athlete a
two-time Olympic gold medalist for Team
USA she endured mistreatment and a show
at a show trial in Russia with
characteristic grit and incredible
dignity
she represents the best America
the best about America it is across the
board everything about her
the best about America just across the
board Brittany Greiner the lady
basketball player whose only noteworthy
activity is to date have been playing a
sport that no one watches protesting the
Star-Spangled Banner at that sport
refusing to show up on the court for the
national anthem and trying to sneak pot
into Russia Brittany Greiner represents
the best the very best of America
apparently not the history teacher not
the Marine the dope smoking
america-hating WNBA person whose release
the US was so desperate to secure that
it agreed to release the world's most
notorious arms dealer back to Russia in
exchange I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
evening
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yes it is from Zach Shepherd who
said every time Michael plugs his book
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds an angel gets his wings P.S I've
read speechless and it is a wonderful
book
did we
guys I don't is there are they working
out the Kinks in the control room I
thought I thought we had the ding back
and then I don't know maybe the ding is
a little bit Rusty when I say speechless
oh all right all right let's get a
little faster that's pretty good you
know when you want to uh ask your
friends and family members to get you a
present for Christmas you want to give
them a little hint you want them to know
that you want to order uh speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
there we go uh you're going to want to
pick up the phone you're going to want
to use pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com enter code Knowles there's
no reason zero reason to pay Verizon ATT
or T-Mobile over 80 per month for
wireless Services when you can get the
same service on the same network of pure
talk for half the price with pure talk
you can get talk text and data that is
just as fast for just thirty dollars per
month those other guys are making you
pay for thousands of retail stores that
you do not go to perks that you do not
use and massive profits to keep their
shareholders happy Pure Talk on the
other hand wants to keep you happy which
is why they have invested in a us-based
customer service team it's also why they
give you so many more data options why
would they charge you for data that you
don't need I made the switch I love pure
talk I like supporting veteran-owned
us-based companies that have my best
interests at heart takes less than 10
minutes to make the switch I am saving a
ton of money I absolutely adore for Pure
Talk go to puretalk.com enter code
Knowles Canada wlas save 50 off your
first month that is puretalk.com promo
code Knowles for 50 off your first month
too bad for the Marine too bad for the
history teacher but the pot smoking
basketball lady who hates the
Star-Spangled Banner she gets to go home
who are those people the one who's
getting the most play right now is Paul
Wellen he is this Marine who actually
spoke with CNN by phone uh around this
release of Brittany Greiner basically
saying hey guys hey Biden uh you mind
what what gives man
they've always ensured me to be at a
higher level than other criminals
for whatever reason I'm treated
differently than another
um individual here from a western
country that's also on a charge of
espionage
so even though we're both here for
Espionage I'm treated much differently
than he is and my treatment is also much
different than others held for Espionage
and other presents I would say that if a
message could go to President Biden that
you know this is a precarious situation
that needs to be resolved quickly and I
would hope that he and his
administration would do everything they
could
to get me home
regardless of the price they might have
to pay at this point
so the guys are desperate he's been in
in a Russian prison now for four years I
think it is unlike Brittany Greiner who
was there for about nine ten months and
he's saying guys you really got to get
me out of here and he says I'm being
treated differently than the other
prisoners he's here in a charge of
Espionage the reaction from everybody
demanding his release has been to laugh
this at this charge of Espionage and say
this is totally trumped up nonsense from
Vladimir Putin to use a political Pawn
to but I actually don't know I mean
maybe the guy's a spy I think I think to
make a stronger argument for his release
we should take seriously the possibility
that he's a spy he's got a military
background he went in and out of Russia
a whole lot of times in the last few
years he apparently had contacts at the
FSB so which is the Russian security
service
so let's just say for a second that he's
a spy and I'm I'm not
I'm not declaring that he is I don't
know there's also a lot of evidence that
he was not a spy the CIA denies that
Paul Wellen was a spy because his
military record was pretty spotty and
the Agents he's saying nobody who had
all this kind of terrible conduct in the
military and who was demoted and had all
these issues no nobody uh of with that
kind of a background would be hired as a
spy by the CIA I don't know I mean I I
can see why Russians might be under the
impression that the guy is a spy but but
my point is let's say that he is a spy
let's say that this guy is James
freaking Bond
and he's very very high value
we just gave up a guy who's also
extremely high value we just the guy
that we just gave up is known as The
Merchant of death okay the guy that we
just gave up Victor boot is the most
notorious arms dealer in the world
Russia really really really wanted to
secure this guy's release
and and so let's say Paul Wellen is is
the biggest super spy in the history of
the world Joe Biden still should have
secured his release we gave up a really
really big Russian asset in exchange for
what
a lady basketball player who was
opportunistically taken hostage by by
the Russians as a pawn
because of this issue right now over the
war in Ukraine and because the United
States was was putting all of these
sanctions on Russia and because Russia
wanted some leverage okay I don't even
like Brittany Greiner okay but it's
clear that her detainment had a
political aspect too yes she violated
the laws of Russia yes Russia has the
right to its own drug laws no I don't
really have all that much sympathy with
Brittany grinder trying to sneak drugs
into Russia but obviously this
detainment was political obviously it
was pretty flimsy and so what kind of
deal does Joe Biden make the only makes
is will will give you a very very very
high value Asset that has done very very
very bad things and you can be very
valuable to Russia in exchange for
this lady basketball player but you can
keep our marine you can keep our history
teacher it's just just on its face even
even if you believe all of the Russian
charges against these two Americans who
remain detained it's just a terrible
terrible deal the guy they got is
cartoonishly villainous take a listen
this was up from a 60 Minutes interview
over who Victor boot is
Victor booed uh in in my eyes
is one of the most dangerous men on the
face of the Earth on the face of the
Earth without a doubt Mike Braun the
former Chief of operations for the U.S
Drug Enforcement Administration told us
boot first exploded on the scene in
war-torn West Africa in the late 1980s
elevating bloody conflicts from machetes
and single shot rifles to
AK-47s not by the thousands but by the
tens of thousands so he weaponizes Civil
War in Africa he transformed these young
adolescent Warriors into
Insidious mindless maniacally driven
killing machines that operated with
assembly line efficiencies now 43 boot
from the Soviet Republic of Tajikistan
is a mystery man who reportedly served
in the Soviet Air Force and intelligence
service
the U.S has indicted him on four
terror-related charges including
conspiracy to kill Americans
so not a great guy you know kind of a
bad ombre and they make this trade why
did the White House make this trade we
all know why
the White House made this trade because
Brittany Greiner is a a liberal black
lesbian that's why and in fact the White
House basically admitted as much in the
the big announcement you had Kareem
Jean-Pierre talking about how important
this is espec not for only for all
Americans but especially for the LGBT
LMNOP community and it's so so important
that we get this lady back and Biden was
always going to cut any deal that he
could to get her back not because of any
particular National interest in bringing
this lady back over other detained
Americans but because it looks really
good to the Democrat base and because
it's very very politically correct and
the important part here is that Vladimir
Putin knew that the Russians knew that
too
you would not have seen this kind of a
deal this kind of a week week deal under
Donald Trump but Putin knew that they
would get it under Joe Biden because the
right the Russians have always been very
good at understanding the fault lines in
American politics on Race on sex on
everything and and so they knew that
they would get it and they they got they
they just ripped us off okay
if it had been
okay we released the you the Arms Dealer
and they released Brittany Reiner and
Paul Wellen or and Paul Wellen and Mark
Vogel or something like that that would
have been one thing but that's not what
we got
not what we got at all and so we had the
handoff here and the funniest part about
the handoff is you get the two planes
landing in Abu Dhabi
and you get the the guys walking up with
Victor boot
and you get the actually just one guy
walking up with Victor boot I mean he's
a pretty tough ombre he can handle
himself then you get multiple guys
walking up with Brittany Greiner and
then
they're sort of shaking hands there on
the tarmac you see with the guy and then
there's a film cut
so you see Victor booty shakes hands
with one of his handlers shakes hands
with another Handler and then he kind of
leans and and then there's this cut and
it occurred to me
they cut the footage of when Brittany
Greiner shakes hands with the notorious
Russian arms dealer known as The
Merchant of death
as I said you know that really messes up
our image here that's that's really
going to play into conservatives hands
if they already don't have a
particularly high opinion of this lady
because the only thing she's known for
is getting detained by the Russians and
disrespecting America and then healing
and use your shaking hands with a guy
known as The Merchant of death so even
that they bungle it it's just an
absolute embarrassment another
embarrassment
for Joe Biden and for the United States
very very frustrating
now when when we've got weak leadership
when things are going a little bit crazy
you want to put your assets in something
you can trust that's why you got to
check out Birch gold well the lack of a
red wave during the midterms lead to
more Reckless spending by a more
emboldened Administration higher taxes
deeper inflation if you are not sure
about how the next two years will unfold
or worse if you are sure how the next
two years will unfold you got to talk to
Birch gold group about protecting your
savings with gold Birch gold makes it
easy to convert your IRA or 401K into an
IRA in Precious Metals so you can own
gold and silver in a tax sheltered
account gold is the world's oldest most
proven form of currency when inflation
soars and all other assets go sideways
gold is still there this month you can
get a free gold back with every five
thousand dollar purchase a gold bag this
is
intrinsically valuable gold flexible
bills it's very very cool I really like
them when you convert an existing Ira or
401K into a precious metals Ira with
Birch gold by December 22nd just text
Knowles kwles to 98 9898 Birch gold will
help you own gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account text Knowles Canada
wlas 298 98 98 to claim your free info
kit on gold then talk to one of their
precious metals Specialists with every
purchase you make before December 22nd
you will get a free
goldback this is a great stocking
stuffer Justin time for Christmas text
Knowles kwles2 98 98 98 and protect
yourself with gold today
even a Democrat Senator by the way is
admitting that this is a disaster and
I'm not even talking about Joe manchin
who's a moderate Democrat or Kirsten
Cinema who sometimes helps out the
Republicans Bob Menendez who is a real
Dem you know he's a real big lib Bob
Menendez Democrat senator from New
Jersey he said this should be a moment
of deep reflection for the United States
government to recognize we have a
serious problem with hostage taking of
Americans the Russians and other regimes
that take American citizens hostage
cannot pretend that there is an
equivalence between the Brittany
Grinders of the world and people like
Victor boot the so-called Merchant of
death nothing could be further from the
truth
we cannot ignore that releasing boot
back into the world is a deeply
disturbing decision
why is it disturbing well Bob Menendez
explains we must stop inviting
dictatorial and Rogue regimes to use
Americans overseas as bargaining chips
and we must try to do better at
encouraging American citizens against
traveling to places like Russia where
they are primary targets for this type
of unlawful detention
yeah of course
that's true American citizens do need to
exercise a little bit of caution and
Prudence I remember in my early 20s I
was going to take a trip with a couple
friends of mine and we well we did end
up taking a trip around the Middle East
and going to different places but one of
the places we wanted to go to was the
island of sakotra which is between Yemen
and Somalia and we wanted to go because
it's a really cool looking place and
apparently St Thomas Shipwrecked
Shipwrecked there and it just seemed
like it would be fun to go travel there
and a friend of mine who is a military
guy he said
big hulking dude he goes Michael
do not do not go to sakotra and I said
why not I can handle myself you know why
why can't I go to sakota and he says
because you will just be a walking bag
of money every person there every Somali
pirate every bad desperate ombre is
going to look at you and recognize your
valuable because they take you hostage
then they can get a lot of money out of
the United States
so do not go there okay that's fair uh
and this is true in a lot of places
around the world and one thing that the
United States historically has tried to
do to reduce that risk for Americans
traveling abroad is that we have a
policy of not negotiating with
terrorists and not
not encouraging and incentivizing Rogue
regimes to take Americans hostage it's
it's not that I really don't like
Brittany Greiner and that's why we
shouldn't have made this deal
it's that this deal one is deeply unfair
to the other Americans who've done a lot
more to serve their country than Britney
Reiner ever has who are still being
detained but also
this endangers all Americans abroad if
if all of these regimes now around the
world see that we've got weakness in the
White House and that they can get their
their most prized assets freed from the
United States if they just take an
American hostage and Ransom that
American then you're going to see more
of that behavior this is what happens
weakness on the world stage invites
aggression from our enemies and and it's
it's just really really pathetic if we
had gotten a better deal it would be one
thing but it's just such absolute
capitulation awful awful stuff
habitulating such bad people around the
world speaking of bad people
the people who used to run Twitter are
in some hot water because Twitter files
part two was just published Barry Weiss
is the the person who published it you
saw the first part come out from the
journalist Matt taibi new one from Barry
Weiss
the type of journalist that Elon Musk is
hiring to go through this
is an interesting choice
if they are liberal journalists who have
some problems with the liberal left
they're not conservative journalists
that he's giving it to but he's giving
it to the the liberal what used to be
called the intellectual dark web type
kind of people you know the
I'm a liberal but I'm not a leftist you
know I'm that sort of thing but they are
still Libs I mean they are still on the
left they just are are sick of this
corrupt establishment and all the
extreme radicalism that we've seen in
recent years so Barry Weiss goes through
it
she does a bang-up job
she says the new Twitter files
investigation reveals that teams of
Twitter employees build blacklists
prevent disfavored tweets from trending
and actively limit the visibility of
entire accounts and even trending topics
which is bad enough but then they also
do this all in secret
without informing any users this is an
important release not because it tells
us that Twitter was Shadow Banning and
blacklisting people
we already knew that
but it's proving
just like with the first Twitter files
release
the the main takeaway here is not some
big news item that we didn't know about
before the main takeaway here is we're
not crazy
we are not crazy and the things that we
suspected were happening for years
actually were happening and the people
who were running Twitter and their
propagandists in the mainstream media
were lying to us
the people who run Twitter who told us
this this wasn't happening they weren't
just getting it wrong they were
interesting competent it wasn't just a
mistake they were actively lying to us
they were deceiving us
so who did they get
Dr J bhattacharya
Dr Jay bhattacharya very serious
Stanford scientist who from the early
days of covid argued that the lockdowns
were harmful
and that they would ultimately harm
children Twitter put him on a Trends
Blacklist so at the outbreak of covid
when when it was really important to get
as much information out there as we
could to try to take on the virus
one of the
credential lab coat wearing experts
who was much more correct about covid
than Dr fauci or anybody else he was
blacklisted
that information was suppressed it is
not going too far to say
people's lives were upended and ruined
and
and people died because of this because
this information was not allowed to be
put out there because it was suppressed
by political actors uh then of course a
lot of conservatives were blackballed
Charlie Kirk was put on a do not amplify
list Dan bongino was put on a search
Blacklist so with Charlie Charlie is
absolutely great at Twitter and his
tweets would have a huge amount of reach
just the way he writes them his
personality he's just great at it and So
eventually they said okay we're just
going to suppress his tweets Dan bongino
who's got a huge reach
you couldn't even look him up you
searched for Dan bongino he wouldn't
even pop up and then here's the key
in 2018 Vijaya Gaddy who was the head of
legal policy and Trust to Twitter she's
the one who made the call to ban Donald
Trump when Jack Dorsey was out of the
office she said that the duly elected
sitting president of the United States
can't have a voice in the Public Square
Vijaya Gadi said
we do not Shadow ban
and we certainly don't Shadow ban based
on political viewpoints or ideology
that was co-signed by Kayvon bake poor
who is the head of Twitter product
so these are two people at the very
highest level of Twitter who said in
writing we do not Shadow ban and we
certainly don't shout a band based on
political viewpoints or ideology
we should have known then those of us
who didn't know them I suppose most of
us did know but everyone should have
known them oh they do shadow bear when
you say we don't do this and we
definitely don't do it in this specific
way then you are acknowledging well we
may maybe we kind of do that first part
a little bit no we don't Shadow Dan and
we definitely don't do it on political
viewpoints Well turns out
they did
they Shadow banned they specifically
Shadow band based on political
viewpoints
and at the very highest level there was
a team to Shadow ban but then there was
a team above the team to Shadow ban and
who was on the team above the team to
Shadow ban
Vijay Gadi and Jack Dorsey they were the
ones making the highest level decisions
on who to Shadow ban a practice that
they lied about and said did not occur
they called it visibility filtering
visibility filtering is just a euphemism
obviously for shadow Banning and
apparently Twitter uses this quite a lot
according to one of the Twitter
Engineers that that Barry White spoke
with quote we control visibility quite a
bit and we control the amplification of
your content quite a bit and normal
people do not know how much that we do
so next level stuff an outright Lie from
Twitter
and the thing is to quote George W bush
full new ones shame on you fool me twice
the point is you're not gonna fool me
again
words of wisdom words to live by
when the Liberals clutch their pearls
and they say oh it's so terrible these
right Wingers they're they're
an hour democracy
they don't trust
the big Tech oligarchs they don't trust
the
bureaucrats in Washington they don't
trust our elections they don't trust are
scientists in the lab coats think it's
so terrible why well why don't we trust
them
it's not our fault that we don't trust
those people
it's your fault it's their fault
we don't trust the medical establishment
because of Dr fauci because he lied to
us we don't trust the big Tech oligarchs
who control the Public Square because
they lied to us we don't trust the
people who are running the elections in
2020 and 2022 for that matter in certain
places because they lie to us and they
upend all the rules and then they
Gaslight us and then they relieve
themselves on our legs and they tell us
that it's raining they're the ones who
did it
okay you lives you libs are the ones who
did it
so I'm not going to
shed one tear I'm not going to make one
single apology for not having faith in
the institutions that you control
okay we're we're not the ones who
destroyed our sacred democracy you are
okay you're the ones we are responding
and the only rational and prudent way
that we possibly can do not believe
these people
oh the media oh my goodness how did I
forget the media they don't trust the
real news the real journalists and the
neckties and the New York Times and I
know I sound like I'm doing an Arlo
Guthrie song and the New York Times And
The Washington Post and the CNN right we
don't trust any of them they are
complete Liars we they have no
credibility whatsoever if I see a
headline in the New York Times and CNN
in the Washington Post and I see a
headline on frogs turning gay
news.biz.co.uk I am going to believe the
latter of the latter has more
credibility if I see Dr fauci telling me
something about medical science and I
see an African witch doctor wearing a
big headdress doing a rain dance telling
me something about medical science I'm
going to trust the latter he has much
more credibility okay especially when
we're talking about matters of life and
death and you will die someday and
that's why you need a will and that's
why you've got to check out epic will a
will determines how your financial
assets are dispersed as well as your
personal property it ensures that your
end-of-life decisions are honored when
you are unable to see them through for
parents a will determines who will raise
your kids should you and your spouse die
before the kids are of age without a
will the state will make that decision
for you if you were just starting out
and you don't have thousands of dollars
to spend on an attorney but you want to
make sure that your savings your
belongings and your family are all
protected you've got to create your will
at epicwill.com today epic will bundles
your last will living will Healthcare
power of attorney hippo release and
durable Financial power of attorney it
only costs 119 bucks for a single person
to create a will and when you use promo
code Knowles kwles you will save 10
percent
do the responsible thing do it now don't
put it off be an adult go to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles
kwles to save 10 on Epic Wills complete
will package that is epicwill.com promo
code k-n-o-w-l-e-s
Barry Weiss doing great work on covering
that story speaking of courageous women
the sister of the supreme leader of Iran
I did it again
I'm an American I should pronounce it
Iran
Obama is in my head
I'll try it again
the sister of the supreme leader of Iran
of the Ayatollah has come out against
her brother and against the regime she
said I think it is appropriate now to
declare that I oppose my brother's
actions and I express my sympathy with
all mothers mourning the crimes of the
Islamic Republic regime
from the time of Khomeini the first guy
after the Iranian Revolution Iranian
Revolution to the current ERA of the
despotic caliphate of Ali Khamenei
she writes this in the letter
I don't bring up the story to to say
anything about Iranian politics I don't
really care that much I mean I care and
that I care I hope that people live good
flourishing lives but I I don't have any
particular interest in Iran
and I'm going to get in trouble for this
take and Media Matters is probably
already clipping it out as we speak
I bring it up because
the success of the mullahs in Iran
actually should give some
some encouragement to U.S conservatives
the success of the Taliban in
Afghanistan
should give some encouragement to
American conservatives and I'm I don't
mean
hear me clearly I am not saying we want
Sharia law in the United States I am not
condoning the actions and the laws of
the balas or of the Taliban in
Afghanistan I am simply pointing out
that
liberal modernity
taken to its extremes
transient kids redefining marriage
killing the babies destroying our
culture the the consequences of liberal
modernity
are not inevitable
and those two countries for all of their
sins for all of their many problems
have proven that okay
just take it in that very narrow sense
before the Taliban took over in
Afghanistan it looked the nation looked
like a Western Country women were
wearing mini skirts walking down the
street it looked like liberalism and
secularism and modernity were inevitable
there
before the Iranian Revolution Iran
looked like it was on the same path as
all the other modern Western countries
I'll say it for the thousandth time I
don't want the malas to come in in
America or the Taliban or anything like
that but that wouldn't happen because
the reason that a conservative backlash
in Iran and Afghanistan looked like a
Muslim caliphate is because those are
Muslim countries with a long Muslim
tradition
a conservative backlash in America would
look very very different because America
is a Christian country
okay
but there could be
a conservative Revival that's all I'm
saying all I'm saying is liberal
modernity which we are told by the
Crooked establishment that wants to kill
your babies and trans your kids and ruin
your marriage and stop you from
reproducing and hook you on drugs and
Outsource your jobs and open your
borders and destroy your whole country
those people
have have put us into a trance and made
us believe liberal modernity is
inevitable we're just all zombie Walking
there's no way to preserve any of your
Traditions or anything like that
that's not true
those those regimes that throughout
liberal modernity in other parts of the
world
despite all of the pressure including
from the global superpower
have have remained basically in place
for many decades now
half a century now
and maybe America could do it too maybe
we could do it the right way you know we
know I'm not saying we start
we start implementing burka laws okay
but we could enforce traditional
American laws against obscenity we could
stop killing all the babies we could
stop chopping off kids genitals we could
we could get back to normal it is
possible don't believe the the liberal
Elites who want to discourage you and
who want to pretend that they are
inevitable
they are not inevitable
okay they they try to they try to make
their numbers and their power seem much
larger than than they actually are
speaking of foreign relations
there's a story that very few
conservative commentators have have
reported on but it it matters because it
tells you a lot about our foreign policy
right now the UK
has now decided to import American Gas
and that's good news right we're happy
when American Energy does well but the
story is a little quirky because the UK
also decided to ban its own gas
so the UK
will not produce its own natural gas it
won't it won't Frack itself but it still
wants natural gas so it will import it
from the United States and people are
calling this very expensive hypocrisy
but that's what's happening and you're
seeing a broader move throughout Europe
to turn back toward American Energy
well what had been supplying their
energy before previously their energy
was coming from themselves
in the relatively distant past now or
from Russia Russia was supplying a lot
of Europe's energy and as a result of
the Ukraine war
and as a result of the sanctions more
specifically that we've all put on
Russia Europe is having to turn back to
America for its energy
this is why the United States has a
stake in prolonging the Ukraine war it
serves the U.S national interest to to
turn Europe away from Russia
and Europe turns to Russia because
Russia is very very close and Russia
funded a lot of environmentalist groups
to go in and convince Europe to stop
producing its own energy simply go to
Russia but then Russia invades Ukraine
the United States decides this is a good
opportunity to put a bunch of sanctions
on Russia and turn Europe back to the
United States all of this to say
what what you are seeing is in politics
and especially in international politics
is usually a lot of propaganda it's
usually surface level stuff the debates
that we have on on the surface of these
issues very often are not what are what
is motivating U.S policy how did America
just overnight decide to that Ukraine
was the most important country in the
world and the greatest democracy ever in
history and how did that happen
just a few years ago the Democrats were
impeaching Donald Trump for colluding
with the ukrainians right just a few
years ago we were told that Ukraine was
this horribly corrupt country and it was
all terrible and so how did that change
overnight such that everybody posted the
Ukraine flag immediately
because it serves the U.S
interest and it serves not just the woke
people it serves deep much more
entrenched interests and it brings me
around to this final Point here which is
we have been told
for months now that Russia is a
genocidal awful evil terrorist regime
and we have to do everything we can to
stop Russia from getting weapons from
from using those weapons on the poor
Ukrainian people
we just released
the biggest Russian arms dealer in the
world
while Russia is occupying Ukraine
doesn't that seem like wait hold on
didn't you were just telling me
Democrats that we've got to cut off
Russia's supply of arms we've got a
we've got a harm we can't allow any
military Russian assets to be anywhere
around the world and also okay we're
going to trade their the worst arms
dealer on Earth for this basketball
player because it'll give
Joe Biden a nice little headline
that's what it's amazing how quickly
people's opinions can turn the daily
wires post-production team by the way is
expanding and is in need of new talented
video editors to help with the ever
increasing volume of daily wire plus
content our video editors work on a
variety of content including our daily
podcasts long form interviews and
original YouTube videos as well as shows
like this one the Michael Knowles show
Ben Shapiro's debunked series from
Jordan Peterson and a host of other
daily wire plus content we are looking
for highly creative people who possess
strong technical knowledge of the video
editing process at least two years of
previous professional video experience
and is uh this is required for this
opportunity so be sure to have your real
or work samples prepared as they are
required for consideration for this
position this is based in Nashville for
details and to apply visit dailywire.com
Knowles and click on careers that is
dailywire.com Knowles today
now finally we get to my favorite time
of the week the mailbag
sponsored by Pure Talk go to
puretalk.com select a plan and enter
code Knowles to get 50 off your first
month before we get to the mailbag there
is one clip I really wanted to get to in
the show this just popped up last night
and uh
I I don't even want to introduce it is
Al Pacino from the Video Game Awards
please join me in welcoming to the game
awards Al Pacino
so cool thank you
oh thank you thank you hello everyone
it's really good to see you here
uh this is uh an experience for me
what I didn't expect but here I am
as usual doing my surprising thing to
myself
but uh anyway
uh I I I may come as it may come as a
shock to you but uh I I I I'm it's hard
for me to see the teleprompter
it goes on the hot we don't have time to
play the whole thing the the whole
appearance by Al Pacino it's Video Game
Awards for some reason is just a true
Delight I bring it up for no reason in
particular other than it delighted and
amused me and sometimes people say that
I bear a passing resemblance to Al
Pacino in uh The Godfather so I I am
just pleased that Pacino and I share
another thing in common which is that we
often have trouble reading the
teleprompter I I okay I think I think
it's time to get to the mailbag
let's go first question
Mr Knowles it's your favorite resident
bass player and hopefully a candidate
for your show's Stinger coming at you
again with another question
as a metal musician I wanted to get your
perspective on your thoughts of satanic
imagery in music now as a heavy metal
musician it is a huge proponent in a lot
of it but looking behind the scenes at
the artists and the bands themselves
they do not advocate for satanic imagery
most of them are actually Catholic the
only genre of metal that actually is a
proponent to practicing Satanism is
black metal but others like thrash metal
or death metal they don't actually
believe in practices of Satan or
anything of that matter
any insight would be fantastic shout out
to Ben Davies
coincidentally a Catholic buddy of mine
is a metal musician
so I I believe you
I believe you in that I'm sure that
most metal musicians don't worship the
devil and many of them are probably
perfectly sincere Christians
there is a problem with metal though as
a genre and it's really a problem of
rock and roll and Hip-Hop and metal
would be an extreme version of this
which is that the music itself forget
about the lyrics forget about the
symbolism just the music itself is
problematic because as Plato tells us
music more than any other art form is
able to stir and shape the soul it's
able to bypass the rational faculties
when we're listening to music we are
just sort of swept away it can totally
change our moods and we will not really
be all that conscious of it
and this is why
back when our civilization was more
serious we took music much more
seriously we make fun of Footloose now
and you know these puritanical people
who are getting upset about kids dancing
around to some rock and roll or
something but it is a serious question
if you acknowledge that music can shape
the soul which musicians more than
anybody would acknowledge so
this is why traditionally
the music that was encouraged in our
civilization was music that was A
melodic and eventually harmonic
as well but percussion is something that
people have always been a little more
wary of because percussion just cuts
right to the core uh it it moves your
body you know when you're at the club
you know and you're having your your
vodka soda or whatever and then you're
listening to dubstep and then that beat
finally drops
right and you're you just your body
starts convulsing and you're not you're
not intending to do that that's just
sort of what happens
so in metal it's a very percussive genre
of music you get those drums you're just
going constantly you get that bases even
you know keeping that beat going in you
and so that can shape your soul and that
can take you away from your rational
faculties and so you've just I'm just
saying bro you got to be a little bit
careful next question
hi Michael Arun here with another
question about scientific philosophy I
just got done listening to your speech
uh science is fake and as both a
scientist and a loyal Michael Knowles
fan I endorse it completely now my
understanding is that you claim science
is a set of physical models which are
meant to offer us predictive power over
nature and which may help us predict the
motion of the planets uh GPS clocks and
whatnot but it does not necessarily
represent the underlying nature of
reality but you also alluded I think
correctly to the scientific process
whereby new models will offer iterative
improvements over old models example
einsteinian relativity versus Newtonian
mechanics uh does this entire process
not rely on a fundamental assumption
that there is an objective reality which
exists apart from our subjective
interpretations of reality and that
these new models are meant to converge
on the truth thereby prohibiting us from
abandoning the idea of objective reality
altogether
yes excellent excellent question an
observational Rune that is the idea and
that's why people like bacon people like
Newton especially people like those
early scientists tended to be deeply
deeply Christian I mean you think of
Isaac Newton
he spent the last Decades of his life
more or less ignoring science and and
interpreting scripture so yes I'm I'm
not saying that
the scientific Endeavor and scientific
worldview from the beginning are hostile
to fundamental metaphysical truths or
religion or anything like that the
problem with the scientific worldview
though is
in focusing exclusively on the physical
it inevitably makes an idol out of that
out of the physical world and focusing
on phenomena and matter it makes an idol
out of that and it is very easy to to
believe as a result of the scientific
representations that we're also dazzled
with these days that the fundamental
part of reality is physical
this is why you hear people say well uh
yes Michael Mann has a special
relationship in the cosmos but literally
the Earth revolves around the Sun
or look the basic objective facts are or
you'll even you often hear this on the
on the debate over transgenderism
what is a woman what is a man look
a woman is her chromosomes okay that is
what is objectively true that's a fact
that's why we're all talking about facts
right but
yeah it's true that a woman has X
chromosomes generally speaking but
that's not all a woman is and that's the
physical is not the fundamental fact
matter is not the fundamental fact of
reality form is much more fundamental
than matter is the metaphysical my soul
is much more fundamental than my my body
is and the two are intertwined so you're
you're right about the process of
Science in principle and in theory but
the problem is this is a fallen world
and so we naturally fall prey to the
idols that we make and and the
scientific Idols ultimately do tend
toward a materialist worldview even if
the earliest scientists the guys who
kicked off the Scientific Revolution
would have found that bizarre next
question
hey Michael this is Marissa I've got a
question about reading people and
reading their intentions I'm not the
greatest with this I feel like I've
trusted the wrong people or befriended
the wrong people because I couldn't
initially tell that they had bad
intentions or were just trying to kind
of use me for things like that and you
strike me as the kind of guy who's very
perceptive so I would love to hear any
tips or things advice you might have to
better read people and better understand
them thanks
really good question
working in politics
and show business actually acting too
would be it would be another thing that
gives one some insight into this they
they impart very few hard skills working
in politics doesn't teach you how to do
all that much doesn't teach you how to
be an engineer doesn't teach you how to
bake a cake doesn't teach you how to
build a house doesn't it but it does
teach you how to read people
actually if you've ever taken an acting
class or worked in acting or theater or
anything like that that imparts very
virtually no hard skills it does impart
the skill though of reading people
you have to I mean politics is about
bringing people together
politics is about
figuring out how people tick what
motivates them and how we can all live
together
and then acting is about
figuring out characters and building
characters and so if you do either or
both of those things well you have to be
able to read people and know a little
something about people but it's not a
science
and that I can't give you her three tips
here's how to read people and this is
what you should do in your life it is it
is much more an art than a science
because people are not just little
mechanistic computers that can be hacked
that's what the libs believe that's what
the great reset people believe that's
what our our ruling class believes but
that's not actually how people work
people are a mysterious thing
and so my advice to you if you want to
get better at reading people you have to
spend more time around people you have
to look deeply into people and you can
do this with technical learning and you
can do this with practical learning so
the technical learning how do you get to
know people and what motivates them you
should read the Russian novelists you
should read Shakespeare you should read
Victorian novels you should
you can read and engage in the sort of
art that is focused on the inner life of
people and then in a practical matter
you you need to be around a lot of
people and you need to go to social
events and all different sorts of social
events you should go go to the bar you
should go to the book club you should
you should go to church you should spend
time in real Community not in virtual
community not not just online not just
texting people but in real life because
the the way to read people
is not just he said this
or he believes this he's a liberal so
he's going to do this or he says that he
works this job and so no it's so much
more subtle it's little tells it's how
they move their face it's where they
look when they're talking to you it's
it's when you're when you're at a
cocktail party with somebody
and you're having a conversation and
he's looking over your shoulder to see
if someone more important walked into
the room it's all these very very subtle
things that you're going to pick up and
then like a like a soldier clearing a
room you know like a like a cop going in
and apprehending a bad guy like anyone
who
needs to perform in a Split Second
you're just going to read things in a
way that is subconscious
you're just going to go in and you're
going to have a gut feeling and that's
why people in especially in politics
will say oh I just got my gut you know I
just I just go on my gut well that's why
because you've you've trained your gut
over a long period of time next question
hi Michael my question is regarding your
Italian Heritage would you ever consider
living in or spending time raising your
kids in Italy or do you love America too
much to leave also what is your favorite
Italian Dish to eat do you have any
recipes that were passed down in your
family anyways love the show thanks love
Ashley
thank you Ashley very very good
questions very important questions I
would
I would live in Italy for some short
period of time I would not move to Italy
I would never leave my country I would
not be an expat
one I really love my country but two is
right to love one's country you know I I
actually think it's proper to love one's
country and to be a part of one's
country and I think one's identity comes
not just from one's individual desires
and inclinations but from one's place in
community because man is fundamentally a
political animal man is a social animal
we are not fundamentally individuals
that's I take the Aristotelian view of
what man is and what defines man not the
liberal view for instance in terms of my
favorite pasta dish I don't know my
favorite Italian Dish probably veal
salty Boca or my my real favorite dish
is sweet little elise's homemade lasagna
with the fresh pasta with the Bechamel
meat sauce with it's just absolutely
magnificent a recipe there are many
recipes passed down to my family
last night by the way we just had fresh
gnocchi fresh delicious it was just
absolutely delightful with meatballs uh
so that would that would be my favorite
sweet little elisas
lasagna we have many more mailbag
questions to get to but you're gonna
have to do it on the member block okay
and this is Friday this is fake headline
Friday I need your help
to uh help me beat Ben Davies he has
given me four real headlines one fake
headline I need you to help me get this
headline correct so head on over right
now if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]